just this is nine to zero this is crazy
uh supreme court unanimously rules
against immigrants if they enter the
country illegally and they have
temporary protected status they cannot
get green cards
i just here's what i love about this and
i appreciate it that it says in this
it's just kind of a funny headline that
it says the supreme court unanimously
rules against immigrants with temporary
status and then right below okay like
illegal immigrants and then at the very
very very bottom of the article in the
last paragraph monday's decision does
not affect immigrants with tps who
initially entered the us legally it's
like
so it's set so the the headline
literally is immigrants but this is what
they're doing they're they're they're uh
they've been consistently conflating
illegal immigrants with immigrants for
years
for years
why
because it's an easier it's an easy way
to win the discussion like who wants to
say they're against them it's much
easier to say you're against illegal
immigration you don't like when people
break the rules and they come into your
country despite the fact that your
nation has set up certain parameters for
someone entering so that we can monitor
who's coming in and they've decided to
disobey those rules
that's reasonable how could you disagree
with that but
if you say that those people are just
mean haters who don't like immigration
in general
so it keeps dumb people in check because
anybody anybody who actually discussion
yeah anyone who can actually read this
and discern what's happening knows
they're not talking about immigrants who
enter the country illegally and they're
not talking about refugees that's a big
difference is a refugee and an illegal
immigrant if someone's fleeing hostility
we have a duty to take them in i think
you know most people do
there's limits yeah within limitations
so you don't destroy your own system but
exactly illegal immigration is not it's
not that well and this is the point
right
yes we should be helping people who need
our help but the well-being of the
people already living in the country
needs to be taken into account there has
to be some kind of balancing act but if
you support unrestricted illegal
immigration what you're saying is that
balancing act doesn't matter as many
people can flood this country as want to
without there being any oversight and if
you disagree with that you're a hater
and the way they convince people of that
is by framing it as a discussion of
people who are pro-immigrant or
anti-immigrant rather than people who
are pro-illegal immigration and
following the law bro there's there is a
a chaotic destructive entity hacking
away at the roots of this nation and
it's it's hard to even say that we
remain a nation
i know a lot of people on the left will
immediately they attack this idea if you
come out and you say that we are at risk
of not being a country anymore the left
will immediately start attacking you why
it's true it's a vulnerable vulnerable
spot for them let's think about a few
things the democrats in the debate stage
in last year and in the in the year
prior in the election cycle raise their
hand to give taxpayer-funded medical
care to non-citizens california's
actually done it
you've got democratic interests and
media conflating illegal immigration
with legal immigration why because they
they want it
you've got the same ideology this woke
group
literally rewriting american history the
1619 project now it's being resisted but
when you like we mentioned this last
week but when you've got
people rewriting history and teaching in
schools a re we've totally revised
american history now washington state
this this was a jason ranch reported
this is mandating critical race theory
so you know they're teaching kids fake
american history what's going to happen
these kids are going to grow up and
they're going to be like america was
founded in 1619 as a slave ocracy and
you're going to be like that's made up
we know it's made up we actually had
debunkers and news doesn't matter they
teach it to the kids 20 years from now
they'll say i know what's true you're
lying that's my reality
so now the history of this country is is
under attack the embassies are flying
flags that ideology the people who are
pushing that ideology and politically
are trying to flood the country they're
they're saying illegal immigration and
immigration are the exact same thing
legal immigration is fantastic i think
it's great we get a lot of high skilled
work we we basically when we have legal
immigration
in many instances i was reading this
this uh story about it
there's like
a good portion of those who immigrate
legally are high skilled workers and
then a good portion are low-skilled
workers but the high-skilled workers are
bringing their innovation their
technology their resources and ideas
into the us it's great for us
illegal immigration not so much it's bad
for everybody it creates a massive
supply of of a workforce at the lower
level making work so you you have a
massive supply and limited demand for
low skilled labor making it more
difficult for people in america
overall
it's just very bad for lower income
individuals
they're they're conflating these things
they're claiming that
you know the right are the ones
destroying democracy that are attacking
attacking democracy if this keeps going
this direction and i think it likely
will because republicans don't do
anything about it republicans engage in
the conversation the democrats decide
they do then in 20 years there will not
be a united states as we know it the
history is going to be 16 19 and there's
going to be a complete
shift in in demographics in every
different place especially with biden
you know shuffling immigrant children
illegal immigrant children all across
the country it is going to erode at our
civic institutions and i think this is
one of the big reasons democrats keep
saying democracy and why they've been
saying it for a long time we're not a
democracy we've never been a democracy
we have democratic institutions like our
electoral process but we're a
constitutional republic democracy makes
it easier to subvert the will of
you know of the citizens so now we're
going to be entering a period where
yeah your money is going to get stripped
away from you joe biden is is putting an
invisible tax on the working class and
the lower class in a variety of ways and
it continues to just eat away at the
united states
and what's going to be done about it i
mean there's a resistance but a
resistance is not a reversal so we can
talk about this we can vote for certain
poli p for certain individuals but in
the end you get republicans who
agree with the framing from the
democrats agree with them in the long
run and in 10 years the republicans will
completely be completely aligned with
the debt with where the democrats are
today and the democrats will move
continually in this other direction
until what
yeah i mean the entire vote falls apart
and i've said that i hope i'm not
starting to sound like a broken record
on these points but i've said this in
the past i mean leftism is just social
decay
transformed into an ideological system
of thought and so it almost seems
inevitable but on the other hand i think
we can turn this around i think you're
absolutely right that all republicans or
conservatives are trying to do is resist
instead of putting forward an ideology
of their own and that's a huge part of
why they're losing and i'll sound like a
broken record again but this is also why
i believe like fundamentally
conservatism has to be rooted in
catholicism you have to have values that
you're forwarding you can't just say
x y and z that the left is trying to do
are bad but we're not going to give you
a coherent system of thought that should
replace that or which is undergird or uh
excuse me undergirding our present
system that we should stick to
yeah republicans aren't against things
democrats are for things yeah yeah
exactly
exactly and if and if that's the case
then you're gonna get a bunch of
leftists saying we want this and
republicans saying slow down and that's
it and then eventually they get what
they want now
i think the trump era trump supporters
want things and they're demanding
exactly and so that was a problem for
the left
i guess the issue is
if you live in the blue-pilled reality
of the democrats
you know the republicans are smart
snarling demons who have ultimate power
and everything's their fault when they
could barely get anything done
the left frames everything the democrats
frame everything as if we don't get what
we want republicans are evil the
republicans aren't even asking for
anything
so it's basically them saying we've got
a bunch of what we want we want more
what the republicans are evil for not
giving us more of what we want yeah
exactly there is there is no pushback
for the most part from the republican
party except for
these new these new trump republicans
trump himself
that was a problem for all of us and the
democrats because the democrats are
obstinate they will not stop
they will not shut up they will not back
down
finally you get republicans willing to
fight back and then it's an unstoppable
force and an immovable object eventually
it's just there's going to be a a
fracturing of the united states i wonder
if this ultimately is just uh
where it comes from
is it a a psychological operation are we
under attack are we being manipulated
you know what i mean yeah we i'm not
sure
i don't i don't think that it's uh i
keep thinking about the roman empire um
when they
it seems like things are so stable here
but then it also seems like we kind of
don't have a culture in the united
states we've got like so many cultures
that it's like how do you pinpoint what
we are as a nation we have the
constitution that's very basic
the roman empire people would migrate in
and it was very dangerous when people
would come in because what would happen
is they'd migrate in nothing would
happen then their friends and family
would come migrate in and all of a
sudden you'd have like a hundred
thousand people in a city from another
country and they'd overthrow the mayor
and take control of the city yeah and
then the state the surrounding lands so
that is very real with immigration
that's why you have to be careful about
your borders and about letting too many
people of different cultures that don't
value the constitution the government
necessarily well can you imagine if like
170 000 people poured over the border of
a country and then the president of that
country released a video welcoming
people and thanking them for choosing
his country why did biden do that that
literally happened in march at the end
of march yeah in march 170 000 people
was a 15-year high in terms of people
spilling over the border and biden
released a video granted it was for uh
people who are being naturalized as
citizens but what he says is thank you
for choosing america it takes a lot of
courage to cross over that border and
come to this nation etc so it's just
setting us up for destruction ultimately
very yeah and it would be one thing if
he was saying that to people because he
he was speaking to people who are
becoming citizens but the problem is
when you release that kind of messaging
at a time when the left is insistent
upon conflating immigration and illegal
immigration you are basically giving the
okay to everyone who wants to come into
this country illegally to do so
but this mixed messaging that they've
been giving now is like if you're here
we're gonna we're gonna say it's okay
but don't come it's basically saying but
if you get here and no one knows then
we're gonna treat you like you're fine
exactly so that's insane it's insane
it's completely insane unless it is
their intention to get as many people
here as possible and then naturalize
them and then build a loyalty and a
relationship between those people in
their political party so that they win
forever i'm not that perfect that would
happen
maybe it wouldn't and i hope it wouldn't
but i think that if there is a plan
that's it look at uh south texas mcallen
we were talking about this i mean
hispanic areas flipped they're going
republican and i think that's fantastic
and there are many conservatives who
predicted that that kind of thing would
happen because i think mexican people
tend to be more socially conservative
and that's where most immigrants are
coming from but that's definitely not
something the left has been banking on
yeah the left has sort of assumed that
they own immigrants in immigration and
they tend to believe
that
they can depend upon virtually every
minority group to support them
i'm just uh
man i'm i i don't know if i have
confidence in uh the current opposition
to what the democrats and left have been
doing
to believe that we are headed down a
path where we can preserve our values
free speech
i think uh for one and um the right to
bear arms obviously but more just like
our moral framework and our uh
our our values as a nation when you get
a bunch of people who aren't from here
who come in
it's mostly just about a nice place to
live it's not about the values of the
country that's why when you take the the
citizenship test they ask you you have
to learn the history of the country they
want to you to know and respect this
country and what it represents who the
presidents were and things like that
when people come here illegally they
don't know or care about any of that
they're just coming and saying here's my
chance you know to to get some resources
now the left's response is usually like
oh it's no big deal you won't even
notice and it's just absurd to think
that there's not going to be an impact
you mean to tell me that when it comes
to climate change you know all of these
farting cows and all these individuals
using
electricity and air conditioning it's
extremely bad
you you mean to tell me that the
individual has an impact on on on
climate change but the individual coming
in here illegally doesn't have an impact
on our economy how about we frame it
that way right the united states
produces more carbon emissions than a
bunch of other countries so the last
thing we want is more americans right no
i guess they're they're fine with it
they just want to transform the economy
as well so what do you what do you mean
you tell me you're gonna invite 170 000
people in one month but then also take
away their means of actually maintaining
themselves through the economy they
can't use electricity they can't produce
carbon then all you're doing is
encouraging them to go on these long and
dangerous journeys then once they get
here you make them do surf labor in
exchange for for nothing but limited
access to resources meanwhile the ultra
rich are allowed to do whatever whatever
they want yeah exactly you're kind of
building a
an underclass and
there's a few things you said there
which i'd like to dive into
when you're talking about immigration
it's sort of the distinction between
illegal immigration and legal
immigration
there are a number of people who have
made the criticisms that well you know a
lot of conservatives say that they're in
favor of immigration but they're against
illegal immigration but that's
incoherent because then they should be
okay with us allowing anyone into this
country as long as we make them a
naturalized citizen through some kind of
process but the entire purpose of having
an immigration system is as i said
earlier oversight and so i think what we
need to be doing in terms of our
messaging isn't just saying we are
against illegal immigration we have to
be talking about the immigration system
which we want to build
or the one which was supposed to be here
which we would like to maintain
and that is one which says if somebody
wants to come here as you've stated they
have to prove to us that they are
interested in promoting our values did
you know that john stewart once uh a few
years ago six years ago or seven years
ago advocated for the draft
whoa jon stewart said volunteer work
bring back the no to the draft i think
he said like draft people into doing
volunteer work though well he said for
the greater good of the country yes he
said the draft that he said but it could
be you know what you know what he i
could simplify his entire quote down to
a very simple sentence service
guarantees citizenship oh john stewart
endorsed he didn't say that though okay
but that was basically what he was
saying it would give people a skin in
the game mistake
i agree but i agree with jon stewart
about his statements on the draft but
here's here's where it gets complicated
service guarantees citizenship the
problem is i mean there is already a
kind of service which is taking place
when people come into this country
they're doing jobs not that americans
aren't willing to do but that americans
aren't willing to do as inexpensively as
they will do them and so they're already
providing a service but the problem is
at some point
you over saturate the market
and make life more difficult for people
who are already here so that's why i
would be a bit apprehensive about that
even if they are coming here and
providing some kind of service at some
point we still reach a limit where there
are too many people and no matter how
badly someone wants to come here and
serve we just can't let them could you
imagine if the us said like
literally anybody served two years in
the armed forces as like front line
infantry and you'll get citizenship oh
my goodness
that's roman style yeah yeah the use
would have like a million ground troops
every year added to their ranks
so they don't do it exactly like that it
would be
that's a pretty evil thing in my opinion
well yeah and it would also i would
imagine you mentioned the romans at this
but i would imagine that would be a
really horrible military strategy
because you have a bunch of people who
aren't committed to the ideas of your
nation and don't necessarily have any
loyalty to it and now they're on the
front lines of your military yeah but
those people could be completely
anti-america and they could just be
infiltrating your armed forces but it's
a it's the zapp brannigan strategy you
know if we get into a full-scale
conflict with another nation and you can
just send wave after wave of your own
yeah very evil thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time